they say Maxine please don't say
impeachment anymore you've already said
that you support impeachment of the
president I think it's I think it's a
it's certainly something that needs to
be on the agenda I absolutely do I mean
Bill Clinton was impeached but not
removed from office we don't want to be
in a situation where the president is
deranged and we've got nothing that we
can do about it
well the midterms are fast approaching
and some Democrats are having a tougher
time hiding their obsession with
impeachment ken starr the man who led
the Clinton investigation in the 90s
that brought about the former
president's impeachment calls the
process hell for the country he's out
with a new book today titled contempt a
memoir of the Clinton investigation and
we're also joined by former US Attorney
and Fox News contributor Andy McCarthy
gentlemen is great to see you judge
Starr let's go to you first
I remember the 1998 like it was
yesterday and all that was happening at
the time Bill Clinton at the time had
about a 40 percent approval rating 42%
mid-40s but after he was impeached his
rating approval numbers started going up
up up is that part of what you're
thinking may happen here if the
Democrats actually go for the brass ring
on impeachment well it could very well
happen because the American people and
part of the message in my book is be
careful what you ask for because I do
think impeachment is hell it's held to
go through for the American people even
though they're very strong feelings on
one side and then on the other side that
is not our system we have impeachment in
the Constitution it's an important last
resort and the country did not feel as a
whole that Bill Clinton for all of his
crimes and he committed crimes and we
prove that he committed crimes that he
should actually be removed in his last
year-and-a-half in office we have
elections in the country and those
elections mean something midterms coming
up why in the world are the Democrats
some of the Democrats seriously
discussing impeachment I think it's
folly but
that's the politics I think it's just
very bad for the country it is ultra
divisive judge if you could do it all
over again would you still accept the
job as independent counsel I mean
knowing what you know now I know it's a
ridiculous question in a way no I think
about that question and the answer is
yes I would but I would not have made
the second time around the blunders I
made especially dealing with the press
as I described in the book my decision
to sit down with a real snake in the
grass named Steven Brill and to be
interviewed by him and for him then to
completely distort what I had to say and
other journalists said that was a
distortion because you were destroying
what I had to say and and that brought
on an investigation and so forth so when
I think about how I conducted it we
tried to conduct it and I think we did
with integrity I'd make a lot fewer
mistakes and in Rosen Stein worked for
your team of prosecutors way back when
Andy I also want to get your thoughts on
the new text messages released today by
Congressman mark meadows they show more
communications between the former FBI
agents Peter struck and leased the page
and to some they point to a coordinated
media leak campaign intended to harm
President Trump the correspondent
correspondence ends with struck
congratulating page on an article being
planted on Carter page Andy your
thoughts are there are other ways to
read this well there are a couple of
ways to read it Laura although I must
say that you know when you have a
situation like we have here we've had a
lot of evidence of high ranking FBI's
officials leaking you have to take that
into account I've been in investigations
where people I don't know that they use
this phrase as clumsy as you know our
press leak strategy but there are some
times that you have to have a strategy
because you're being killed by leaks and
you're trying to tamp down on them then
there's another way of looking at it
which has never been my preferred way as
a prosecutor but there are prosecutors
who endorse this and that is this idea
of tickling the wires this idea that you
take information that you have from your
investigation
leaked it to the press so that it gets
out and then as you monitor your wires
see if the people who are mentioned in
the stories say and do things that are
indicative of consciousness of guilt or
conceal my evidence and the like again I
don't I don't think that's a proper way
to go about an investigation but it is
done well his struck attorney 8 and
Goldman said that the term media leak
strategy instructs text refers to a
department-wide initiative to detect and
stop leaks to the media and then mark
Meadows responds to sit today by saying
the American people aren't buying his
misdirection in fact mr. struck did lead
an effort to control leaks as his
attorney suggests it's worth mentioning
that such an alleged effort was clearly
a failure it should raise questions
whether there was a serious effort at
all and finally an D on the issue of
impeachment you're very skeptical about
the idea that the Democrats would either
have enough people to vote for
impeachment members or that they would
they would be able to get any
Republicans on board enough to get to
that critical level well I think if they
were wise they'd heed judge Storrs sage
words but I think if they're just gonna
play brass knuckles brass tacks politics
they're gonna need more than a margin of
a few congressmen or representatives in
order to have enough in the way of
numbers to get even the simple majority
that you need to file articles of
impeachment in the house I just think
they'll need a more comfortable margin
if they want to go about that all right
judge judge finally does mother need to
wrap this up judge Starr I mean it's
like he hasn't gotten everything he's
wanted he didn't get Trump for a
sit-down doesn't the lights gonna happen
is it time to kind of get the show on
the road here well given what we know
there's no evidence of collusion and I
think the the American people have
wanted to know that for a long time the
two indictments that have been returned
do not point to collusion at all so yes
especially with respect to Russian
collusion now there is another
perspective and that is we don't know
what other assignments he's been given
by the Deputy Attorney General rod
so stay tuned I'm gonna say just a
closing word on impeachment as I
described in the book 31 Democrats in
the House of Representatives voted in
favor of impeachment and yet even with
that modest but still 31 is not nothing
thirty-one Democrats supporting we see
what eventually happened there was
another way and I think that way needs
to be discussed is the impeachment
process something you should be reserved
for the gravest kinds of offenses high
treason and the like is that the way we
should hide right yeah truly high crimes
and misdemeanors let's get rid of
parsing language and say this is the
disruption of an election so what should
we do and there was not a serious
conversation with respect to a
resolution of censure we need to have
that debate all right fantastic thank
you gentlemen